passé bien confortable de tirer sur le
pianiste bruxellois pour des réformes
qu'on a envie besoin de faire chez soi
et qu'on ne veut pas assumer
politiquement est ce à dire que la
plupart des dirigeants dans un double
discours c'est à dire totalement
totalement ce discours c'est la faute à
bruxelles alors qu'en fait on fait des
réformes pour soi même c'est tellement
fréquent et prenez l'exemple de
l'endettement on dit toujours c'est
bruxelles qui impose l'austérité mais
son dtc mourir c'est aussi simple que ça
et puis est ce que je constate tout de
même c'est qu'on a aussi tendance
parfois à mettre sur le compte de
bruxelles des décisions qu'on prend soin
même une chose que nos concitoyens ne
connaissent pas ils ont l'impression
parfois que la commission jument de la
commission c'est le gouvernement de
l'europe nous avons beaucoup de pouvoir
c'est vrai et être commissaire européen
est une responsabilité certaine mais
nous n'avons pas tous les pouvoirs nous
sommes une instance qui propose une
instance qui exécutent c'est nous qu'ils
ont les propositions législatives ou
financière c'est nous qui administrons
au final le budget et les
réglementations mais ce sont toujours
les états qui décident toujours